tell me what is it about your particular
characters in the show that you enjoy
playing so much well granny's pretty
feisty I love that I love that they've
written granny not to be you know
cookies and milk and I'll sit down and
I'll read you stories like I get you
crass boy I know I know and I'm sorry
and I get to say some we had the couple
of bigger episodes together but my
character mostly just shows up and says
a comment here there but usually they're
pretty choice comments oh I love that
yeah I mean I loved how the boys made
read the wolf I mean I thought that that
was just such a brilliant twist and they
told me about it early on into the first
season and I lost my mind I just thought
it was so genius and and made so much
sense yeah I think it just especially in
like this world that they've created
that that of course that's what of
course that's how it goes you know and
so in my mind that's just how the story
I mean I believe the fairy tales that
they've written them about tell that
world is and that they just know
something that we don't I know like
they'll take one aspect and then make
blow that part up rather than the
traditional what we know the story to be
like I loved them when we found out you
were the wolves
what and the way they write with the
directions and or the stage stage
directions in between the script when
we're reading it oh you won't believe it
this is gonna blow your mind you know
the swear yes people that's right it's
the wolf you know you're reading it
because when we read it - it's the first
time and it's pretty exciting to stay on
the characters they made granny's dinner
I like the irony of that and I wanted to
ask you well what how do you like this
type of irony that the writers are
giving to your characters you being the
wolf you being while having a dinner
every tiny one yeah it's not being won
because technically you're eaten by the
wolf but this time you are are you going
I have the diner and so I was supposed
to be it and I'm supposed to be dinner
yeah ah nice I've never heard that can
I've ever heard that I did but that's
great that's great Eddie and Adam on the
line you told me we got sick
who told you that your wife my little
cousin your little cousin yeah that's
great mm-hmm
well you know what I'm sure the boys
Adam entity I'm sure they have thought
of that because there's layers and
layers that you can't you watch
something you go oh yeah that makes
sense
um but personally I love having granny's
diner because everything happens at
granny's diner every party every funeral
of Reed you know welcome back oh my god
where are they
and everyone eats at Granny's so
granny's has got some good food and
that's very she it's really cheaper
there's a board above of the like where
the cash register is and it's got all
the prices for everything you can get
yeah you think you big breakfast for 60
cents there I know I know I think the
prices are locked in 20 years ago when
when yeah and there's the first cursed
game everything froze so the prices
never went up although we all have cell
phones and like really great clothes you
get to wear great clothes and bail like
sewers thousand dollar shoes where do
they come from we don't know she sells
her used books on eBay there but we
can't get out of story from that side
making you obviously won't in the show
much they season I that remains to be
seen that intelligence I'm sure just it
got cancelled as you know so I have some
more time on my hands I did not have a
ton of time I was supposed to be around
more than we thought
I was able to last year so that was that
was unfortunate but yeah most likely all
I'll be running around on my cape I hope
so I was season four yeah I hope so I
hope they writes more may god yeah I
think we need to have another fight
another fight yeah we just kind of
regressed a little bit I know I know and
go back and way back in time yeah so I
can use my red hair why would you know
why would you guys like to see your
characters going
the next season and the story I've
rolled mm-hmm well I mean season three
ended on such a you know new note I
think with you know a new villain coming
potentially and you know that all these
crazy things have been happening and and
so I don't really know where they're
gonna take season four but I can pretty
much guarantee it'll be something that
you've never thought of that none of us
have ever thought of and it's gonna be
amazing and there's lots of suggestions
out there on Twitter what have been your
favorite one so far suggestions well
there's a lot of people think we're
going into the frozen with Elsa I'm not
saying that for sure I do not know I'm
just saying what I've heard Facebook and
Twitter and the fans you guys know more
they know more than we do
I just hope we get to come along for the
ride you know this Neverland was a great
story land line but all of us in
Storybrooke just stayed quietly in
Storybrooke and waited for them to come
back so so it would hopefully something
that filters back and forth between
Storybrooke and some other land be it
frozen or go back to the enchanted
forest I love the inside of to do like a
whole season just everyone and I guess
they kind of did that this year a little
bit but like whole seas I'm just
everyone the Wardrobe the costumes and
everything screams just that's rich yeah
and you're usually out in the woods yeah
or in green screen yeah yeah but just
warm and dry as opposed to do it I mean
it's obviously such a fantastic world
not officially but in terms of the
characters that populate it I'm curious
apart from your own are there any other
characters that you enjoy just because
of the performances or because they're
characters that you perhaps grew up with
or kind of identified with from your own
experience of fairy tales I mean I Snow
White was the first movie I ever saw and
so I've always loved Snow White and I
loved that they made Red Riding Hood and
Snow White best friend so I love it with
Ginny we always have a ton of fun
together so it'll be interesting to see
what
what they didn't have there's a new baby
now and their their life together and so
it'll be interesting to see how that
works into the story you'll be the
number-one babysitter uh yeah I mean
I'll be Henry and the baby so although
Henry probably doesn't need to be
babysat anymore yeah that's growing up
there's a new baby I'd be out of a job
yeah as far as the cast members and in I
everybody I just think people are doing
amazing work on the show Lana is
fantastic and she is such a complicated
role to play being the mayor and the
Evil Queen and and young Regina so it's
like I think she's got the Skookum role
for a female actress as far as what they
write for her and Robert Carlyle his
Rumpelstiltskin it's just mind-blowing I
love how he always puts the emphasis on
not the obvious choice of word you know
I just think he has a blast with that so
those ones I identify with but for me as
a kid
Red Riding Hood was the fairy tale that
I grew up with and we used to play as a
kid we take turns and sometimes the
Wolfman would get killed
sometimes the wolf and sometimes he
wouldn't sometimes granny would be eaten
sometimes she wouldn't you know so
there's all different versions I guess
amazing I like this one no she's the
dinner diner
how much training did you have to do for
Whitey's character nintendo's um a lot I
was very tired last year I actually one
of the most exciting things that I did
in training for it was I went to the
Secret Service office in downtown Los
Angeles and had a tour of their building
and spoke with a bunch of officers and
you know there's pictures on the wall of
all of them you know with the presidents
at the you know in the inauguration and
I think the head of the Secret Service
who was showing us around as we're
walking down the wall or down the
hallway there's this wall full of photos
and this picture from President Obama's
inauguration the first one
and he's just you know walking like
running alongside the president walking
down the road with the motorcade and
everything and he's standing right next
to me and you would never guess that the
most intelligent and like humble people
the ones that I met and yeah it was just
it was fascinating to sort of see how
that world worked and then I had to also
do a lot of weapons training which was
crazy Canada so I had no gun six I have
to inspire this you look so natural
though you look great well thank you
thank you it's fine it was actually fun
I'm it turns out I'm a pretty good shot
good I'm just talking about Red Riding
Hood again I guess you know it's a
character that kind of permeates popular
culture around the world and in most
versions of the story it's very much a
parable about don't trust predatory men
you know men are evil and it's all about
you know women not trusting me I'm
curious to what extent you think your
character being the wolf or sell kind of
turns that on its head a little bit and
do you feel kind of this is saying
something different with this story that
we haven't seen anyone else before I
yeah I mean actually when I was doing
research for the role in the first
season I read quite a bit about the like
mythology behind Red Riding Hood and
back in the day one of the sayings of
losing your virginity was called seeing
the wolf was when you lost your
virginity so that's apparently you know
part of the mythology that that led up
to that story but I think that's the
thing that's so great about the show is
that they Adam and Eddie have taken
these female characters that have you
know historically sometimes been you
know weaker and have you know saved by
the men and just imprint yeah exactly
and they've turned everything on its
head and the princesses saved themselves
and red is a great example of that as
being the wolf as you say you know I I
think that you know it's a really great
empowerment device for women and I think
that it's great that sudden like you
young girls are watching it too because
they're gonna grow up with these female
characters that can take care of
themselves and don't need someone else
to fight for themselves yeah and yeah
that's a really great thing to put out
in the world to stay on this with the
wolf I mean you have kind of an animal
side in the English oh how is it you
just like let your instincts loose at
some point it must be a very different
way to play them in intelligence for
instance well you're very pretty
hmm it's very different and it was
actually it was really it was really fun
to go kind of back and forth a little
bit because I finished intelligence and
then went back to the end of the finale
- yeah one time and it was really it was
really fun to kind of go right from that
like bound constricted character to you
know Ruby's very she's very passionate
yeah animalistic you know she's she's a
wolf you know she had that that's what
kind of fuels her and and it's in how
they write hurts and I can't not do that
as I play her and so it's it was really
it was really fun to kind of have that
juxtaposition I like at the end of that
one episode where you just say I'm just
yeah I'm talking about favorite episodes
of course fans have there's a few
personally there any looking back
they're especially proud of or just have
very fond memories of making well of
course the fondest one was red handed
season one oh my god coming up on the
top of Mount Seymour in the snow and the
fog like they didn't have to have a fog
machine or anything it was just there
the beauty was it was fantastic and and
we had such an arc in that episode our
characters where the backstory was
revealed and and it was great and our
relationship was revealed and we went
through stuff and came out the other
side and then going back and forth
between fairytale land and Storybrooke
so for me that was that was definitely
my best
my favorite ya episode as well it was it
was so it was so magical like truly say
like we were up in the snow shooting one
day and I kid you not I took a picture
of it and it was on I think it was on
Instagram at some point but Jenny was
standing there and there were all these
birds flying around us and she put like
a little like food in her hand and a
bird landed on her hand and was just a
picture of her standing with a bird on
her finger no worries no I costume I was
just like where are what's happening
this is magic like it just it was just
it was very special and really yeah well
Helga who's our first two seasons was
our script supervisor now she's one of
the producers she just always would run
Aronica it's magic it's magic and just
spreading them that's contagious you
know it's really it's there's a great
feeling on set everybody we know we're
part of a good show and especially first
season when it was just coming to life
everyone just loved coming to work and
the crew would come in on Monday morning
and everyone had watched the episode the
night before so that was it's pretty
great
pretty special talking about kind of
favorite episodes I'm gonna say that my
favorite bad character is Peter Pan
because he's incredibly evil and I loved
the way that they turned him around
responsible but no in this time is
incredibly bad and the new character the
bad one one from frozen do you think
well she can be that evil do you think
any actually any bad guy in the future
can be as evil as Peter Pan man it was
horrible
really he was so hello yeah that he was
horrible but he was horrible but don't
you think it's who speaks to you because
I loved what Pete Robbie did with Peter
Pan I loved and how they wrote that
character but I also what Rebecca Mader
did with the Wicked Witch of the West
that spoke to me so for me maybe it's
because I'm a woman I just she just got
in and she just enjoyed and relished how
evil she was being in the shows did it
with a smile on her face so for me that
particular brand of evil resonated a bit
more so I guess my answer would be yes
because it's maybe for you you might
find anyone as evil as Peter Pan but it
will depend on the future character I
think it is and I I these like Adam
Neddy are they're not finished writing
out there they have a lot of ideas
cooking so uh-huh yeah good so you do
you can see any other characters brought
in from that kind of story fairy tale
world whether it be a Disney movie or
you know actual books well he would you
like to see brought into the world
once upon a time hmm people keep asking
if we're gonna do like The Lion King or
animals but who'd be all green screen
and I think it would get pretty bulky
was enough I don't like they did
Frankenstein that was kind of a surprise
so it can venture out I think I think
there are no limits when it comes to
one's another time even Star Wars things
go well we have princess laughs that's
true although that was just a mom um who
do you think what do you guys like to
see well I mean I think I'd love to see
bill from frozen just because you know
who doesn't want to build a snowman yeah
and it's also so popular in contemporary
it can only you know how did you feel
when you first saw Ruby's costume
because it's quite sure I laughed I
laughed very very hard but the thing is
is that it actually completely made
sense to me that she would with how they
were telling the story with how the
curse went in Storybrooke that Ruby's
cursed with the story of Red Riding Hood
being about a cautionary tale about sex
and everything that the the opposite end
of that would be a girl who has you know
this like overt sexuality and is you
know basically the opposite is not
cautious of predatory men actually seeks
them out is the predator herself and so
I thought that it made total sense but I
was
Oh chi-su and every time of day y'all
cut she take her shoes the heels taking
these shoes off and put your uggs on her
something he walked so beautifully in
them but cut my fade the worst poop do
you remember those my thigh high res yes
I had these you can't totally tell it's
leaves you wear them with a red pants
but these like plastic thigh high red
boots with platforms that are about this
big that like lace up and they're kind
of comfortable actually but they're just
they cut they pinch as well and went to
some shady stores to bite it yeah it was
fun though grinding like a roller Oh
happening I remember after you watch
season one you went oh my god they shot
so much of my I bent over a lot and
maybe definitely zoomed in my god I
didn't know that was happening we all
knew it was happening you're just acting
away like laughs so that I can be player
you